[Música]
en el último día de esta cumbre de las
américas ahí se encuentra entonces una
ciudad de los ángeles excede esta novena
cumbre natalia cabrera nuestra enviada
especial natalia muy buena mañana
seguimos en nuestro cubrimiento ya en
ese último día la migración será y es
uno de los temas centrales de esta
declaración final de esta cumbre que se
sabe de lo que va a incluir el documento
final natalia
hola raúl buenos días desde la ciudad de
los ángeles en este el último día de la
cumbre de las américas efectivamente hay
algunos anuncios previos a la
declaración final que se llamará la
declaración de los ángeles quien va que
espera el presidente joe biden entregar
al final de este encuentro en ella se
incluye un pasaje específico sobre la
migración que incluiría varios puntos
importantes entre ellos un camino a la
ciudadanía para algunos de los migrantes
migrantes así como distribución de
refugiados entre los países que integran
las américas esto era ya un previamente
habíamos conversado con la portavoz del
departamento de estado cristina rosales
ella nos había comentado que también un
punto de la migración es el más
importante el anuncio más importante de
esta declaración de los ángeles en el
que además se espera entregar fondos a
través de la inversión de compañías
estadounidenses para atender
principalmente las causas que generan la
migración hacia aquí hacia el norte del
continente esto se haría como les
comentábamos al principio de la semana a
través de inversiones de compañías como
coca-cola pepsi google entre otras que
estarían
los fondos y llevando sus compañías sus
inversiones a los países de
centroamérica este tema ha sido polémico
precisamente por la no asistencia de los
principales de los presidentes de los
países del triángulo norte que son los
que generan la mayor cantidad de
migrantes hacia el norte del continente
es el plan éste incluiría un marco de
trabajo para la asistencia de las
comunidades en las regiones
así como también plantar
e iniciativas para combatir los
desastres humanitarios y un plan de
ayuda a haití para frenar la migración
del de haití y esto todo por supuesto
son avances la declaración final de los
ángeles se conocerá sobre las cinco de
la tarde hora local y será el secretario
de estado- anthony blinken el encargado
de dar a conocer a la prensa ya todo el
mundo que contiene exactamente la
declaración de los ángeles que
culminaría con la novena cumbre de las
américas natale le pregunto ahora cuáles
fueron los hechos más destacados del que
fuera el cuarto día de este encuentro
regional el día de ayer jueves y que
otros esperaba para el viernes
ayer fue el día más importante para los
jefes de estado y de gobierno reuniones
aquí en la ciudad de los ángeles del
presidente yo bailén dio inicio con su
discurso oficial en las sesiones
plenarias en un centro de convenciones
allí entregó un discurso súper
contundente diciendo que por supuesto lo
que les menciona que la migración es lo
más importante para atender en esta
declaración de las américas no quiso dar
muchos detalles pero dijo que otra de
las causas que siguió atender era la
protección de las democracias en la
región como también les hemos mencionado
a lo largo de esta semana en la no
asistencia de nicaragua cuba y venezuela
ha suscitado un montón de polémicas
porque el presidente de méxico andrés
manuel lópez obrador la presidenta de
honduras y el presidente de guatemala no
vinieron a esta cumbre y algunos en
respuesta precisamente a esta decisión
del anfitrión de no invitar otra cosa
que sucedió durante esta primera sesión
plenaria de jefes de estado y de
gobierno porque el presidente de
argentina alberto fernández criticó
duramente la decisión de eeuu de no
invitar a esto los países esto es
importante porque previamente el
presidente de venezuela nicolás maduro y
ha dicho en caracas que iba a ser
precisamente el presidente alberto
fernández el encargado de llevar su
mensaje aquí a la cumbre de las américas